they say money can buy happiness but
ended by friendship in order to find
answers I posted an ad on Craigslist
seeking someone that I would pay to be
my BFF while testing their skills as the
ultimate friend this is the story of how
I bought a friend off Craigslist I am
being paid to be somebody's best friend
it seems interesting
I guess thank you for coming I'm excited
my hope is that even though I'm buying
your friendship today that that's just
an investment and that it will be as
valuable if not more so than a real
genuine friendship yeah no shame do you
think you're a good friend I would say
so yeah I hope so
why do you think you'll be a good friend
to me specifically I'm very blunt if
you're like doing something weird with
somebody and I'm like oh man like Joe
like don't do that as your friend I'm
going to look out for your best needs
I'm gonna show you love and I want you
to show me love okay yeah I think I'm
off for this task there are many
variables when it comes to friendship
but I want to highlight three very
important things to me
their loyalty I don't want you sleeping
with anyone I'm dating yeah I don't want
you coming after my family secondly
honesty I tell you you look good in a
shirt
I'm being honest what he said I said
that's a nice shirt great $24.99 great
value lastly how would you stand up for
me yeah okay if if someone's coming up
and wants to stab me yeah I expect you
to take the knife if we accidentally do
kill him we're hiding that murderer
though if we kill someone we are
reporting to the police because it is
against the law to murder someone right
then hamed even have what it takes to be
my best friend I decided to get to know
him a little better before I tested his
skills what's you prefer holiday well my
family is Muslim so we have like a big
and a small lead oh I broke pretty poppy
how about you what's your I love
Christmas yeah it's a plastic feel
people are just generally kinder through
the holidays what's the most
embarrassing thing that happened to you
in college one time I got all my food in
the dining hall and I trip over a flat
surface oh and I'm like on the ground
food everywhere after I just finished
paying I'm
seem to be fun but I still wasn't
convinced he was best friend material
friendship is about good times and bad
times my first test for Ahmed was to see
if he could be vulnerable with me my
last serious relationship was about two
years ago the thing that sticks to me
about that relationship is the way it
ended it and in some dramatic blow out
there was no screaming or yelling it
just life happened and you know it just
and you spend two years with someone and
it's just sometimes it's just it's sad
to to look back and think about you know
what could have been so a life goes you
know things that bring you down to bring
you to a different direction here's to
that
here's that how about you do you have
anything you want to share all right
there was like a hard time in my life
where I was in junior in college and my
family it's like you know it's there's a
lot of pressure to get like good grades
and like to do well in school and I was
supposed to do this like fast-track
program that my university had I didn't
like studying and I'm taking practice
tests and you have to score like a 650
at the same time I was also applying to
be an RA I took the test and had like my
final interview for RA all in the same
week so I finished the exam and scored
like a 540 later that evening I'd found
out I got rejected from the RA program
as well I had like called my mom right
afterwards so like tell her both bad
news at the same time I guess I kind of
like rip the band-aid off and she didn't
know this but I was like low-key crying
on the phone and I was like and I was
like holding the phone away from me
because it was hurting so much I was
like god damn I just like screwed up
being some things just don't happen for
a reason and then sometimes better
things will come for the next test I
organized for a co-worker to run into
our set and start bullying me my hope
was that Ahmed would step up and defend
my honor
like at bars or something yeah
no I think it's awful he just came out
of nowhere I was actually genuinely
unsure what that was I waited for Ahmed
with bated breath if he couldn't stand
up for me our entire friendship could
crumble Wow
hold ah this is my friend you're talking
to so if you could if you could not
that'd be that'd be great he is my
friend for life right here and he's a
great person and his video idea was
phenomenal because look how great of
friends we are
it's like like this uniform nothing but
pretty close pretty close it's getting
an oddly aggressive what you did just
now I'm never gonna forget that
I decided to send them on one final
mission to determine it all I wanted
Ahmed to know me well enough on a best
friend level to buy me a personalized
gift
[Music]
earlier today we talked about the
triumvirate honesty loyalty and whether
or not you stand up for your friends I
will be evaluating you on those three
qualities when it came to honesty we had
a very intimate moment in the pop-up
park and I genuinely was very moved by
the story you told about the hardship
you went through at college because we
connected on a level that not a lot of
friends do you gave me an a-plus yeah
yes right here all right so more to come
loyalty loyalty is a very important
trait in a relationship and today we
built loyalty through the times we
shared together I will give you a B+ I'm
thinking I'll take it standing up for
each other today I was viciously
attacked he attacked me with his words
for a good solid 15 seconds before you
said anything so for that I will give
you an a-minus okay Wow whoo I believe
the last thing that I can evaluate you
on is the gift that you bought me that's
true
should you close your eyes close your
eyes close your eyes okay all right open
them up you said you love Christmas so
much I decided to bring Christmas to you
[Music]
you were very passionate about Christmas
and I saw that in the store and just
like knew it I think that when people
hear that I was new to be my best friend
for a day if all we thought I was crazy
but I honestly think that today we've
built a good chemistry I think that
there is something here and I I don't
know what you're doing this weekend but
Friday I'm in a Halloween party are you
yes if you would like to come with you
know what sounds like a plan
just to make it clear on Friday when we
hang out as friends I will not be paying
you I'm very excited Ahmed was the best
friend I could have paid for we even did
a bestfriend photo shoot to end the day
he was truly someone I'll never
yeah if we had met like a house party or
something like that there's like no
doubt we would have like ended up
talking and talking about like all this
random that we both like
[Music]